[Music]
[Applause]
um
on the last evening of my 25th college
reunion
there was a party in a tent there was
dancing and music and noise
so much noise that a lot of us started
to drift out of the tent
so we could hear each other talk and
catch up with classmates that we had not
seen in more than two decades
as i talked with my friends i made an
astounding discovery
eighty percent of them were unhappy with
their lives
i feel as though i've wasted my life and
i'm halfway through it
they said i don't know what my life is
all about
now i was privileged to go to yale
and we were standing on a summer evening
in the middle of yale's old campus
and the people that i was speaking with
were
privileged and highly educated and
financially well-off
in positions of power and they had
the first house and the second house and
they had the first
spouse and the second spouse
and 80 of them were unhappy with their
lives
who was happy the 20
well we had studied literature and
renaissance rhetoric
and we were the theater people and the
history geeks
we had studied classes for the joy of
learning
not because we thought they were going
to direct us to a specific job
we still got jobs we were living our
lives
expansively with life's ups and downs
and we'd not did not feel that we had
wasted a single minute
and as i spoke with the 20 to the
happier 20
i discovered that each of them knew
something about their life purpose
because they knew five things
who they were what they did
who they did it for what those people
wanted or needed and what they got out
of it
how they changed as a result
does that sound hard it it's not it's
actually really simple
in fact it's so simple that you can
learn your life purpose now you're going
to know your life purpose now in the
next
five minutes would you like to know your
knife purpose in the next five minutes
can you be a little bit louder because
they're making a lot of noise in the
tent and there's just this silly little
microphone next to my cheek
to hear you would you like to know your
next purp your life purpose in the next
five minutes
thank you actually it's not even going
to take five minutes
so can i share something else with you
if you're like a lot of us you have
wondered and worried about your life
purpose for a long time
and there are books and magazines and
workshops and seminars about it in fact
amazon lists 151
928 books that refer to
how you can learn your life purpose
well i know some people who have spent
their entire lives
trying to learn their life purpose and
look we can all agree that the
unexamined life
is not worth living but if all you're
doing is examining
you're not living
so let's figure out the life purpose
right now together
who you are what you do who you do it
for
what those people want and need and how
they change
as a result shall we do it all right
everybody
on the count of five shout out your
first name one two three four
five fabulous that was the first one
only four to go that's who you are
right now what do you do what do you
love to do you love to
write cook design create ios apps
write code crunch numbers
talk teach what do you love to do and if
there's a lot of things that come up for
you
focus it down by asking yourself this
one question
what is the one thing that right now you
feel supremely qualified
to teach other people think about that
in one word hold it don't release it yet
on the count of five
what do you do one two three
four great that's what you do
now think about who you do it for
picture them in your mind
be ready to say it on the count of five
hold it don't release it yet
one two three
okay who do you do it for let's see it
one more little bit louder please
over the people in the tent who do you
do it for together
thank you that is the spirit that we
need okay now
what do those people want or need what
do they want or need
that you have that they've come to you
so you can give them this thing what do
they want or need in just one or two
words
hold it don't release it yet and on the
count of five one two
three four five
fantastic now this is the best one how
do they change
how do they change or transform as a
result of what you give them
on the count of five how do they change
or transform
as a result of what you give them 1 2 3
4 5.
terrific now we're going to put this all
together kind of in a sentence okay
everyone together louder than the people
in the tent
who are you what do you do
who do you do it for what do they want
or need
how do they change as a result
fantastic you have all just done
something that people who went to yale
could not figure out for 25 years
congratulations give yourselves a hand
now why is that formulation so powerful
because of all those five things that
you need to know to know what your life
purpose is
only two are about yourself the others
three of them
are about other people who they are
what they want or need and how they
change as a result
that formulation forces you to be
outward facing
and all the happier people that i met
outside the tent on that warm new haven
night they were outward facing they were
not inward facing they knew very clearly
whom they served what those people
needed and how those people changed as a
result
and you may have intuited this already
that the most successful people
in any field always focus
most on the people that they serve and
how they are served
themselves happier people
make it a point to make other people
happy and do things that make them feel
well taken care of
and secure if you make other people
happy
life teaches us we will be taken care of
too
so since you all did so well we have
time for just a little bit of extra
credit
one of the most difficult things that
happens when you meet people for the
first time
is they ask you this question so what do
you do
and if you're like some of us that's a
really challenging question sometime
particularly
if you're in these moments where you're
between things or you're
feeling vulnerable or it isn't defined
or
what you seem to do isn't what you
really do or what you're paid to do
isn't how you define yourself
so when people ask you this question so
what do you do and also you got this
monologue going on like why is he asking
me so what do i do it's because
it's that transactional thing where it's
like he wants to know if he should
really spend time talking to me
or or it's that other thing so he can
tell me what he does because he's sure
it's oh really so much better than what
i do
right so when somebody asks you that
question
here's what you do you just say the very
last thing you called out
how what you do changes the people you
do it for
so for example you might say
i give kids awesome dreams
if your life purpose is i write books
for children
so they can fall asleep at night so they
can have
awesome dreams or you might say
i help people look and feel their best
if your life purpose is
i design apparel for men and women who
need affordable choices
so they can look and feel their best
or you might say i help people get great
work into the world
if your life purpose is i train
entrepreneurs and creative
people to take decisive actions so they
can get their greatest work into the
world
and then that little snippet that you
just said becomes your personal elevator
pitch and it will always start the
conversation
because the person that you were just
talking to has to ask you a question
how do you give kids great dreams how do
you help people look and feel their best
can people really get their greatest
work into the world
and then you get to tell them and you
get to share
your life purpose and you get to share
how they may come to learn theirs
too
[Applause]
you